une autre fois ma petite sœur s'est
rendu compte qu'elle avait les cheveux
qui étaient collés par le sang ce qui
s'est passé très vite c'est que dès
qu'on l'a mis ils l'ont mis dans un
fauteuil roulant ils nous ont dit mais
vous inquiétez pas la famille on fait ça
parce que quelquefois on est à peu près
c'est pour emmener tous les résidents à
la salle de restauration donc c'est pour
gagner un peu de temps puis il y a aussi
et moi j'appelle ça de la maltraitance
dès qu'elle arrivait on lui a mis des
couches culottes jour et nuit qu'est-ce
qui vous incite vous soignante à mettre
une couche culotte à un être humain
et là elle a compris a dit oui mais
c'est parce que votre maman des
pertinent n'a pas de perte elle est même
pas un continent pour son bien-être elle
doit appeler ses enfants chaque soir ils
doivent appeler pour elle chez l'enfant
chaque soir ce soir c'était mon tour
bref il a pas sonné le téléphone mais
vous allez faire quoi parce que
maintenant on peut payer 3500 euros par
mois oui et vous voyez votre
mine de rien l'état de votre maman se
dégrader
oui c'est déjà arrivé qu'elle tombe et
préviennent pas forcément c'est pour ça
qu'en plus de la colère on a inquiet une
autre fois ma petite sœur s'est rendu
compte qu'elle avait les cheveux qui
étaient col